[Musique]
voilà c'est la surprise maintenant donné
que ce vent l'équipe de télé maintenant
le travail boulot william bell et à
smoke a fait tout ça pour de penser on
se balade toujours chaque micro alors
pourquoi il est ici j'ai changé de
territoire et bien pour vous dire que
demain c'est l'anniversaire les un an de
télématin pas le même cas mais rate est
horrible et demain donc matinée
exceptionnelle avec william leymergie
toute la société l'énergie si d'autres
avec ce télématin à tous particuliers on
va présenter maintenant oui la malaisie
à une partie de la famille que vous
voyez là parce que les autres les
habille au lit bien évidemment un sort
là en principe on est en pyjama
d'ailleurs nous mêmes et
exceptionnellement on s'est habillé le
corps n'a pas changé alors demain matin
à télématin un petit peu plus fleuri que
d'habitude avec un peu plus de un peu
plus de paillettes c'est à dire un peu
plus d'inviter une chanson
supplémentaire parce que c'est la fête
puisque c'est le premier anniversaire
nous aurons c'est un petit garçon qui
était en même temps que télématin il ya
un an
c'est un petit garçon qui s'appelle
victor il viendra très brièvement de
rendre visite avec trois rois mages et
vous dis pas les noms des rois mages
c'est une surprise d'anciens si par
hasard vous êtes là autour de 19h40 ben
vous découvrirez ces trois rois mages et
puis si vous voulez connaître tout le
film jeunesse le maire est encore plus
on est ouvert à partir c'est au moins le
cas
et puis d'informations demain aussi
alors votre qui peut faire le point avec
patrick joigny mais je vois toujours il
a des gens comme nous tous d'ailleurs
pas toujours mal à des gens là que le
rite et bruce deux ans et les comme
toute l'équipe de rédaction sauf un
jeune collègue qui s'appelle henry et
liquides hui les huit heures qui
arrivent ici vers 2 heures du matin le
nous arrivons vers 16h45 90 16h56
conférence 5 heures avec la fourchette
pour dépiauter l'information et vous
travaillez ensemble comment ça se
passera quand on est un petit peu vous
de vue pour la préparation de cette
émission si on s'est vus la veille alors
la partie journal effectivement il la
prépare
avec celui dont vous venez de parler qui
est en est qui et qui fait la liaison
avec ceux du soir
et puis font leur confiance dans les
actions et moi j'arrive si j'arrête car
s'il arrive on met tous les tous les
confrères qui sont là il ya là où il ya
beaucoup d'absents enfin jérôme caby
michel serait j'en passe christian mary
moloch est ici qui fait le 7h30 et que
les téléspectateurs connaissent bien
puisqu'il s'occupe surtout de l'économie
daniel patte vincent gars qui fait le
malheur la love l'homme qui est très
important derrière là bas il est un peu
plus dans le secteur de notre ami
william et c'est une michelle liste qui
est notre jardinier du matin nos jours
du jardinage voudriez nous suivre le
matin de 6h 57e cousine brigitte
simonetta qui donne le temps pour savoir
si quoi rosé ou non non non non tu
l'aimés tu as sap une performance c'est
certain endroit pour vous c'est qui
quels souvenirs qu'elles qu'elles sont
les plus savoureux par exemple en dehors
de vos cravates donc essentielle
tellement bon c'est pas mal ça veut dire
on allume un problème vous savez à
propos des cravates
il ya deux écueils à ne pas à ne pas
franchir c'est là la cravate trop
voyante parce que comme son nom
l'indiqué on ne voit que ça et puis la
cravate toujours la même parce que ce
qui fait dire aux téléspectateurs ils
peuvent pas s'en acheter une celui là je
vais me payer une moi même alors on est
bon pour les cravates voilà par sa des
bancs de morues souvenirs oui à des
souvenirs professionnels et puis il ya
des souvenirs personnels personnel oui
je me suis retrouvé avec du rap
vous la connaissez alors c'est vrai en
plus que je vous raconte
vous pourrez alors 6h15 l'avenue déserte
qu'on vous imaginez tous sont des
petites voitures et il y avait un feu
orange et puis bon je dirige pas je
passe page et freddie il y avait un type
derrière moi un seul ce jour-là
durablement que j'avais pris un truc non
alors je suis sorti c'était un petit peu
embêté et lui aussi il a été visiblement
en colère et puis bien sûr mais je vous
connu de regarder arte ce matin afin de
beaucoup de dessins animés mon fils
aussi
alors sur le constat amiable on a signé
sa on était deux valeureux crétins
oubliés de la venue comme ça à 6h15 du
matin et ça lui va devenir le climat
c'est un souvenir que je dirais pas il
est amusant
elle a d'autres bon voilà je vous imiter
comme tous les matins je me tourne et
c'est ça la classe passe par die hard et
quand vous voulez mais cher
[Musique]